everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
make some react components still on that
same project that we've been working on
but we need some new components so first
thing I'm gonna do is just kind of break
down what we need where these components
are going to be used and then we'll
figure out the best way to to lay them
out to pull in the data and we'll see
how much we can get done in about an
hour maybe two Pomodoro sessions also at
some point I'll give everybody an update
on my my job search and interviews that
I've had interviews have coming up and
answer any questions that that you all
have so let me get my chat window out so
I can see what you're saying hey
everybody
okay it looks like Sreenivasan it's
their first time so hey welcome glad you
could join us
Harsha it's here - hey how's it going a
lot of people saying hey just saying
everybody and let's go with switch this
up nope that's not it
where's mine there we go Hey alright we
have a couple of first-timers here so if
it is your first time this is how it'll
go I'll put a Commodore o timer on so
it'll be a 25 minute timer
I'll stick mostly to the code for 25
minutes then I'll take a little break
answer some questions and then we'll go
back and forth at the end of the stream
I'll answer any questions that are left
I do have an interview a phone interview
for a job at 12:30 my time so that gives
me about
two hours a little less than two hours
so there's going to be a hard limit on
how long I can do questions so I can go
on that interview but let me show you
actually this isn't what I want to show
you first I want to show you this so I
had someone messaged me on Twitter
Hampus Algrim who's creating this and I
thought it was pretty cool so it's side
view dot app I'll link it in the
description here but you can check it
out but it seems like you can just kind
of drag and drop some code over here and
it runs your JavaScript code live and
lets you play with all the CSS and the
variables the JavaScript variables and
things so it looks pretty cool
and he said that he's hoping to get a
version of it out in November so anyway
just thought I would highlight that
because he asked me to look at it and it
looked kind of cool all right
let's let's start off the Pomodoro timer
and then I'll show you what we're
working on
where's my I guess I have to do it here
so I'm gonna go to localhost I'm also
going to start a end grok server so that
you all can check this out as I'm
working on it I'm gonna paste a link in
here
and if you click that link or copy and
paste that link into your browser you
can see the website as I'm working on it
there's also a test version available
and that's at GCPD Franciscan University
but this one will be the most up-to-date
since it'll mirror what we're working on
here so this is what we need let me let
me just give you kind of a preview of
what our options in terms of what
components we already have it could
maybe use some pieces of them so a good
education faculty
I'll show you some cards that we're
currently using okay so we're gonna
create cards that could potentially be
similar to this I call these like
horizontal cards usually so we would
have an image over here and then a
little bit of text we could do this but
I'm thinking potentially maybe we could
also switch it up and have the image on
the top and the text on the bottom and
have more like a vertical card
the reason being we're gonna have more
text content than we do here so I think
it would look better with more text if
we did it the other way but we could
potentially use these and it would be
pretty easy to use these so we will have
cards similar to this but instead of
faculty members we're going to have
former students so alumni of the
university will have their picture will
have their name will have what program
they were in so business education you
know whatever and then there's gonna be
a little a little bit of text just maybe
a paragraph of them explaining pretty
whatever whatever quote we have from
them so we need space for all of that
and we we may also have a link we can
probably leave the link out for now
because we don't have a ton of info I'd
like to get all the info on one card and
so there wouldn't really be a need to
link to an entire page for that that
person I do see some questions coming in
in the chat so if you have questions I'm
not ignoring you but I'm just gonna wait
until the timer goes off and then I'm
gonna answer the question so if you get
hanging a little bit or if you can't
hang in there right now you can always
come back and watch the recording and
I'll answer your question at some point
so for now in about 22 minutes I can get
to your questions so that's basically
what I'm trying to do with these this
card component we need to display it on
its own page like this so you
we'll be able to go to a alumni outcomes
page and just see a list of all the
alumni similar to what we have here it
also needs to be displayed on the home
page let's go back to the home page down
here we're gonna have a section below
this financial aid section and it'll
have you know potentially maybe like
three depending on the screen size it
will have maybe three cards across of
alumni and we'll figure out you know who
the featured alumni will be maybe we'll
have a featured category and those will
show up we don't need to figure that out
right now
and then I'd also like it to display on
each department home page so we have
pages for I guess we just go back to
education I believe we have a page for
education okay so we have this education
page I like down here to have a section
and it would automatically grab whatever
alumni we have that graduated with an
education degree just show up here if
there are none then nothing would show
up but it'd be good to have that
automatically fill out not only for
education but for any of the the major
program pages okay so that's the plan
let's get to the code so I've been
looking a little bit about at the code
for those cards that we currently have
you can see it I have basic let me make
this bigger it's probably way too small
let's move this over for right now make
some space here okay so I have a graph
QL query if you're not familiar with
graph QL queries you can ask a question
and I'll explain them a little bit later
but basically all this is doing is just
getting some data particularly we want
the name of the the alum we want what
department they were in and we want that
content of what what is there
quote what's there their little
paragraph okay so that's what we want
and then down here we're just getting
that data and for this particular
component we're looping through all that
data and we're we're adding to the Dom
these these cards right so for now I
actually am using this same faculty
cards that we just saw so that's going
to be our starting point just to see I
figure since we have that card built
it's worth it to see if that content
would even fit there I don't think it
will but it's only going to take us a
few minutes to test it and it could save
us you know a lot of time if it does
work so let's do that right now we're
passing in most of the data but we still
need to pass in a the content so let's
call this content and we'll go alumni
node and I believe it is called content
but we'll double-check yep content all
right so let's save that and now we need
a way to get to this this page this
alumni list page so we're gonna go to
our server EJ yes and let's find where
we have alumni so alumni outcomes is the
the path at the end of our URL and we
want that to go to alumni list so
instead of going to our default page
component we're gonna make this go to
our alumni list component now and I
don't really expect this to work on the
first try if it does that'll be awesome
yeah I'll come alright cool so it didn't
work let's see in variant outcomes
alright I figured that might be the case
so I wasn't sure exactly what format to
do this over yet let's get rid of some
of this stuff okay so it wasn't sure
what format to put this query in because
normally we have a separate a whole
separate file for our queries but I
thought I'd try to do it in line since
we haven't done that before and I just
guessed what format we put it in
so let's whip that up you know really
quick here so your fq o
query component let's see this is the
apollo which we're using apollo so this
is the apollo documentation and let's
see oh okay you know what i forgot this
gql so I have to bring in gql which I
don't think I'm bringing in will import
gql it won't put that here and then that
should that should fix our our problem
so let's import it and let's get rid of
this import and this import since we're
not using them anymore
we're brought in gql and then now we'll
say gql I believe that's what all we
need yep GQ Oh wonderful and we can pop
that on the next line it would look
nicer give it a little indentation
alright that should work make sure our
brackets are right I think they are
right I checked them out earlier so
let's say that to what we have now all
right and it doesn't work since X our
alumnae outcomes
okay so the problem here is maybe our
alumni data is not quote alumni outcomes
let's check that out
so we have the code on github for our
our graph QL plug-in or I should say our
WordPress plug-in that has a lot of it's
doing a lot of different things one of
the things that's doing is hooking up
our custom post types to graph QL so
we'll just check that here and I'll
search for alumni outcomes there it is
and our graph QL name our single name is
outcome or we have outcomes so maybe
it's looking for let's see what do we
use we use plural maybe it's looking for
singular maybe we'll try the singular no
same problem my outcome
let me check the chat to see if there's
some obvious problem that I'm having
here actually I just got hey uh let me
let me address this right now so hamro
says I'm 17 and this is an all caps I'm
17 in a dropout which should I do kill
myself
hammer oh definitely don't do that all
right so don't kill yourself I would say
take a deep breath right now and calm
down you have a long life ahead of you
and you can do a lot of awesome things
so number one I would say find somebody
you can talk to maybe a counselor doctor
or somebody and tell them what you're
thinking about so definitely do that
before anything else immediately don't
don't wait but also you're only 17 years
old a lot of awesome things can still
happen to you in particular if you learn
coding it doesn't really matter if you
have a degree you know at least here in
the United States that it definitely
doesn't matter
you can still make money you could
freelance making websites right now and
still make money there are so many
awesome things that could happen you
know you could you could end up getting
a degree you could end up having
multiple degrees if that's what you want
to do you could go to a trade school
like there's something you could just
not go to school at all and still be
fine right it's it's entirely possible I
got a brother that he just cuts people's
grass he does landscaping
he just got a really old truck and made
enough money to buy this truck and a
couple of lawn mowers and he goes around
it does that and and he makes a living
doing that in the wintertime he shovels
people so so you know he's able to pay
his rent and pay for everything just
like that and you know he doesn't
degree for that or anything so basically
I'm saying is when you're seventeen it
thinks it might be harder to see things
in perspective but I'm 30 I'm almost 33
I'll be 33 at the end of the month and
let me tell you like you have so much
ahead of you don't even think about
about ending it now so hammer oh I hope
you're still there and I hope you heard
that if you if you are still there I
want you to get my info in the
description so I'm on Instagram my
YouTube channels there my twitter is
there okay message me on there let me
know you're all right
next time I'm streaming try to come in
and let us know you're all right if you
want more help getting in touch with a
counselor or something let me know I can
help you find one if anybody else has
any advice in this let us know in the in
the chat and hamro I dropped out of
college twice and and still ended up
getting a degree and I have family a
wife where kids job like I have a house
so it's uh it's okay just because you
drop out it it's it's not the you know
it you you haven't ruined your life for
anything it's you're totally fine okay
that was that was pretty serious I
thought I should address that so I'm
gonna go back to the code now but I'm
gonna keep an eye on the chat tomorrow
in case you you message back and I'm
serious about reaching out to me okay
alright so I had come into a little bit
of an issue where it wasn't recognizing
the name what I was what I was trying to
do here so I pulled that query out of C
I pulled this out of a different larger
query so I'm guessing it's probably
something to do with my syntax that I'm
using so let's see oh yes here we are I
need some more curly brackets right the
solution to so many problems in
JavaScript or in this case graph QL seem
to just be curly brackets right
semicolons and curly brackets that's
okay whoa all right we got a different
error this progress that's good
Wow unknown argument last unfilled
alumni outcome Wow all right let's see I
do want to check and see whether it
should be the singular or the plural
cannot query field major program on type
alumni outcome good okay so that's I
think that's that's what we want so
let's try this again all right good we
got another error this is a good area
this means that C we've gotten something
back from graph QL and departments okay
we don't want okay I see what happened
since we got this query from somewhere
else we've kind of copied over an
existing component it was set up
improperly so let's see we don't want
data alumni departments
we want data I believe we'll be okay
with this let's see if that works we
could use our property node of undefined
let's let's use our graphical plugin for
Chrome I think it's this one yeah
let's use this and then we'll be able to
see what we're getting and if we're even
getting the right thing okay cool
so we are getting the right thing here
and it is in the form of data and
everything's within data so it should
have data alumnae outcomes edges okay so
that's yeah we got a should be able to
say
yet when we loop through edges then
it'll be known okay so what we want to
find is alumni outcomes edges here there
we go
let's see how that works
hey okay it worked awesome
so whoa this is a lot more data in here
than I thought there would be Wow
okay cool so we have images that they're
actually displaying pretty well I mean
these images are in various formats and
all of them are the like the face of the
person is clearly visible okay I like
that all right not bad so we are pulling
in the name and we have this learn more
link which will probably get rid of but
we don't have the content being
displayed so let's let's do that so what
we'll do and we're gonna add something
in here to our faculty list item so
we're gonna add in content as a as a
prop where we're destructuring here and
then within our card we're gonna say
right below this this job title which
we're not gonna have let's do let's just
copy this
and we're gonna check to see here's what
we'll do we're gonna check to see if
content exists if it does exist and
we've passed in content as a prop then
we're going to render this component and
we're going to render content we're
gonna pass it through this decode HTML
function and right now we have
typography going as its this as a span
we do have some styles going on that
will probably change the styles but for
now we're just this is just a test so
let's see what we have it is this is
probably gonna look pretty weird yeah
okay and yeah it's terrible okay so this
is definitely not gonna work Wow yeah
some of these are just damn inline
Styles yeah so what we need to do
instead of passing it to this decode
HTML which is not meant to handle all
that HTML would probably want to do the
dangerously set inner HTML okay and two
minutes I'm gonna go back to the chat so
hang in there if you have questions okay
so let's go with dangerously set inner
you know what forget it I'm not gonna go
with it because it's it's very very
obvious that this is not these this
style of card is not going to be able to
handle that much that much text content
I mean even if we made the cards way
bigger what I'm afraid would happen is
at some point like there we just have to
be white space at the top at the bottom
of these images and it's not gonna look
right whereas if we do the vertical
cards they could expand down without
messing with the dimensions of the image
so that's what we're going to do let's
get rid of our changes here since we're
not
use this component anymore and let's
make a new component and that's the
component that we're gonna use with this
data if so let's just start with a
totally blank component
I usually copy and don't do that but
maybe it'll be fun to just do something
you know right from from scratch so
let's go up here to our components and
let's add a new file and let's call this
alumni card and my time is almost up
so what will bring in is will import
react because we're gonna need react and
see what else we'll need nothing right
now let's take a short break and I'm
gonna scroll up to the top answer as
many questions as I can in five minutes
we'll do one more sesh
one more Pomodoro session of coding
available hi from Istanbul from India
awesome welcome psychotic face says my
question is will you marry me I'm
already married so in in the United
States where I'm from you can't be
married to two people at once so I sorry
if you would ask me like 15 years ago
maybe but I can't right now
let's see Yusef says you make react look
easy I I don't know why I can't
understand react reacts I would say
first of all I've been working with
react for a long time in you know
JavaScript land
so like I don't know maybe two years now
I can't remember exactly so I've been
working with it for a while and I
struggled with it a lot and I'd still
struggle with many things so don't worry
if you don't get react right now if you
don't understand it just keep practicing
you will you will get it we're kind of
jumping in in an already developed
project that we've been working on for
months and months so I can understand
why it would be tricky to understand
what's you know what's going on then she
says how can we lazy load components
with loading animations I don't know
that's I would want to know a little bit
more specifically about what you're
using every I assume we're talking about
react here so if you give me a little
bit more detail about your particular
application then maybe I can give you a
better answer but I that's kind of broad
we have checking in from Kenya hey how's
it going
Oh more first-timers welcome okay I'm
she's just as lazy loading and react
please explain okay so if you're gonna
try to lazy load and react number one if
I was gonna lazy learn something I'd
look to see if there are already a
package out there that I could just use
that would handle that for me
hey that number one that's that's not
the kind of thing I would want to code
myself if I was gonna code it myself you
would need to track your scrolling on
your page right so you would need to set
up an event listener to track the scroll
position and you need to track the
position of the potential position of
what you're going to load and then set
it up so that when you get to a certain
scroll position and you probably would
track this through state right so you
would get renders when you get to a
certain position then you load that
right and react and since this is react
gonna say you won't you want to load
that through stay
so potentially like when you get to the
certain position you trigger a state
change when that state change it could
just be like a boolean right true/false
we're gonna load this we're gonna not
load this well normally when the page
first loads it's a false once you get to
a certain point in the page it flips
over to true you get a rerender and you
load that that bit of of content right
so that's how you would lazy load an
entire component if you're talking about
maybe just lazy loading like an image
within a component again my first thing
would be go to an existing library okay
but if you're gonna do it react you know
it would it would be similar really it
doesn't matter whether it's an actual
react component or just an element
inside of a component either way I would
use state and track your scroll to
handle that hopefully that makes sense
live hi from Nepal today the as s says
minimum computer knowledge required for
programming you gotta know how to turn
it on how to install things on your
computer how to type and you can get
started I mean it's really really
minimal you there in browser things that
can teach you how to code so you don't
really need anything special in terms of
computer knowledge you just need to know
how to navigate to a web page and then
it'll start you off like free code camp
will start you off really you're kind of
at a low level if you really just need
something very very basic you could try
scratch search for scratch programming
and you don't even really need to know
how to type for scratch it's just
drag-and-drop blocks but it can teach
you the basics of programming you
without even being able to code so what
I'm sorry without even being able to
type it's really good for for kids but
it's also a nice introduction for adults
in fact in the harbor is computer
science 50 course intro to computer
science the first week they have you
build something in scratch so it's it's
you know it's being used to teach
college-age students and and above so
yeah so I don't be intimidated by
getting into programming they're very
very simple ways to get started where
you need almost no previous knowledge
okay
my timers up obviously didn't get
through all of the questions I see one
here at the bottom that I'll answer
right now
said it from david says jesse you're
gonna stream on your personal account
today I'm thinking about it so last week
I did do two streams on Monday one for
free code camp and one on my personal
account the links in the description if
you're interested you can check out that
channel subscribe if you want to get
notified when I'm doing videos of going
live I might do it so I have a take home
coding challenge for a job that I
applied for with I believe it was with
framed IO in New York City so I would
like to stream me doing that that take
home problem so they they told me that
they expected to take for candidates to
spend no more than four hours on it so
you know I'll try to stream a little bit
of it at least we'll see how it goes
though but I might do that this
afternoon at some point so Eastern Time
this afternoon if you're interested in
seeing that it's not gonna be react it's
gonna be vanilla JavaScript I'm allowed
to use jQuery but I think I'm going to
try to do it all with vanilla JavaScript
so if you want to see it drop down menu
that you can navigate with your like an
autocomplete drop-down menu that you can
navigate with your arrow keys done in
vanilla JavaScript then subscribe to my
channel links in the description and I
will be live-streaming that hopefully at
some point today okay let's reset our
timer we're going to do one more
Pomodoro timer with this we'll see how
much we can get done and so here's where
we're going we're gonna build a react
component that's going to be a a card
component so material design
card with an image in it now here's what
we can do we're using material you eyes
or UI framework we can and should check
out wood as material you I already
implemented it that can help us right so
we don't do that's one of the main
reasons to use a UI library so you don't
have to build all these from scratch
they've done it so let's check out
material you I it is just material - UI
com copy and paste that and in the live
chat so that links in there now and
let's just check out card alright so we
have different types of cards we have a
simple card which it's not what we want
we have a media card and let's see that
that looks like what we need right we
need a media card and let's see what it
says by default we use a combination of
a development and a background image to
display the media it can be problematic
in some situations for instance you
might want to display video or a
responsive image use the component
properties use case okay I think I would
much rather have the image be an actual
image tag as opposed to a background on
a div the one of the main reasons being
a background on a div is not gonna get
picked up by a screen reader so if
someone who's using a screen reader
would try to go through the content it's
not gonna register like here's an image
and here's the description of an image
right we can't put an alt tag on a
background in CSS so let's use this
second example which I'm hoping that
this will add an image tag it looks like
it it will will use the component
property image and then we'll get an
image tag I'm also hoping that we had
lets us put an alt tag it looks like at
least we can have a title okay so that's
that's better better than nothing so I'm
hoping it would just pass these along so
let's see we can copy and paste all of
this so
oh yeah let's let's copy and paste this
whole thing for now and see how it looks
right see how awesome this is right we
have all this to work with you know by
default and what we'll do then object
fit is not supported okay
let's save that for now and then what we
can do is go back to our alumni list and
instead of importing faculty list item
let's import oops we do need to change
this so instead of image media card
let's change this to what do we call
this alumni card so we caught it
alumni card you know what I need to
rename this so that we stick with our
naming convention of capitalized
component names so alumni card and then
we're gonna export alumni card here okay
so we definitely would change that for
now we'll leave everything else the same
and then in our alumni list
let's change faculty list items so every
instance of faculty list item will now
be changed to alumni card okay and we're
gonna pass in all this stuff which
shouldn't it shouldn't make a difference
if we pass the stuff right now because
we're not not actually gonna use any of
it so we should still get rendered the
card whether it's a default data will
just get rendered as many times as we
have pieces of data okay cool so it's
not bringing in obviously the image I'm
assuming they used a relative path for
the image so that's not gonna work
but we can see our card
so it works to render this and we will
need to bring over some of the the other
stuff that that we've been using so I'd
like to bring over our grid system that
we had that we had in place should we do
that I don't think if we should use the
grid system within the card component or
not you know I think it's better if we
don't put a grid system in the card
it'll make our component more versatile
right so what we can do though is add
our grid system to our list component so
that's what we're gonna do
let's copy and paste some grid some of
this grid system into here so since it's
inside our loop or map it's it's going
to be as if it was in the component but
we're not locked into using the same
grid system for every time we use this
alumnae card which we're gonna try to
recycle this alumni card and use it in
at least three locations in the website
so this is I think definitely a much
better way to go so we have this grid
item and we already have this inside a
grid container so that's fine we have
the grid container we need to move over
the class name of classes card so we
have this down here whereas our class's
card
you know what height and max width
actually I I don't think I'm gonna bring
that over I'd like to see what we get
without setting our hide max width just
for now so for now let's take out that
class name we got all the red squiggles
because of indentation so we should I'll
save it it should Auto indent and it'll
get rid of these red squiggles hopefully
it needs a key the key drop we got that
on the wrong
so let's remove that key prop from there
and put the key on here instead there we
are all right that looks a lot better so
when you are going through data and
adding multiples of the same component
to a page and react it you need to have
a key prop that's unique for each one
otherwise you're going to get a warning
so won't error out and crash your
application but you look at a bunch of
warnings all right let's see how that
looks now okay that's a lot better and
so we have three across so now that we
have a different type of card we
definitely could switch up how we're
displaying this and let's let's add in
an image that is actually going to
display so we already are bringing in
this image object let's add it into our
alumni card so that we can display that
image instead of this this image that's
obviously not working so let's see how
we did it here let's pull over a lot of
these these props so I'm just gonna copy
over all of this and let's start adding
these in here so for our headline we're
gonna want to use and we can use yeah
let's pull over our decode HTML as well
just in case we run into some issues
with with special characters and things
so we can use you know for instance for
a profile name we can pop decode HTML in
here and have our profile name in there
for our content we're gonna add it
inside of here
it's not
well let's just copy this for now and
put it in here and let's switch it up
and call this content and let's make
sure we add content let's take out job
title we're not gonna use job title and
we're not gonna have a profile link for
now we have this image object coming in
and we pass in the whole object and then
we check so we have multiple attributes
on this image object that we can use so
that's what we pass in the whole object
so I do want to keep this check to make
sure we have an image object because we
know some pieces of data that we've
looked at before don't have images so if
it looks for the image and there is no
image it's gonna crash it's not gonna
render so we need to check first to see
if we have an image so I'm gonna grab uh
you know what we have this card media
let's just type it out by hand so we're
gonna check for the image object and so
this is like a short-circuit operator so
what JavaScript is gonna do when it
evaluates an end statement is it's only
gonna look at the other side of the end
if the first one is true so it'll look
at this and say let's go over to this
side since we're actually doing
something it'll look at this and say
does an image object exist like yes or
no or is it true Falls right so if not
it's just gonna stop and it's gonna go
on to the next thing so it won't even
look at anything in here if it is true
it's gonna go over here and it's gonna
look at the other side on the other side
we're telling it to render this
component right so this is a shorthand
way of using a ternary or an if
statement so it's it saves you a lot of
space inside a react component so I use
that frequently okay so if there's an
image object
let's render this media this card media
otherwise we're not going to render it
at all and then within this we can get
this for our source we can get the image
object and then the source URL from the
image object whoops
put that on the wrong thing class name
there we are okay so let's get rid of
this static address here and now we're
gonna get our source URL from here it's
setting the height I'll leave that for
now but I'm not sure that's gonna work
in our title for now let's just throw in
our our alt text as our title but we'll
probably change that up okay why is it
still giving me this expecting
annotation of 12 all right it's an
indentation thing all right
doesn't want me to wrap this see what
it's doing okay cool so we have our
images right now I'm just making sure
the images show up so I this is crazy
so our images are rendering right
conditionally depending on whether
they're there or not not just the image
but that that whole section so if we
looked at the code you know all of the
the divs and everything that's
containing this image would be gone as
well we're just not rendering it at all
but it looks like so far
these images are displaying properly you
know there's some like you know maybe
that's kind of cut off a little bit yeah
so some of these are a little bit off so
it may want to do is maybe give a give a
little more height here you know allow a
little more but we also have to think
about like in terms of width like what
would happen with with oh yeah so this
is cut off okay all right so the images
are need a little bit of work I'm trying
to find a more reasonable length here
but it looks like all of these are okay
this is a more reasonable link I could I
can live with this if if we had content
that was maybe this length it's okay hmm
okay this length is good this length is
good this is little much at least if
we're gonna keep it this this narrow
okay let's make these a little bit wider
and give our images a little bit more
room so right now it's the height is
being set to 140 let's bump that up to
200 and see what happens
you know let's see what
as if we just leave the hide off
completely and then let's check our our
grid oh yeah so here let's save that and
then let's also check our grid which
should be on what alumni list yeah okay
I think we can switch this up and at
least have four claws here I think we
could do three okay so we have a column
system in this grid so full width is
twelve columns so in extra small screens
we actually do have full width but on a
large screen right now we want these to
take up three columns so that means it
would be let's try four on here small
with the six so basically we would have
three combs which means we can fit four
cards across on a large screen this one
would be only three cards on a medium
screen two cards on a small screen an
extra small screen should be like a
phone we can only fit one so you'll see
what I mean in a second when we refresh
this okay so now we have a little bit
more space our images should have let's
see what's going on here
okay interesting just make sure images
we took out that height let's see what's
happening here let's inspect this and
see what's going on
I want to see if it's still adding a
height I don't see it there let's see if
there's a a height attribute on any of
these no we're good so maybe that
Heights just being determined by the
width or my hat
there it is I was on here okay let's go
back here and see what's happening also
with our width
okay our spacing maybe that's where
we're getting let's drop our spacing
down a bit let's let's drop it by half
and see what we get here I really didn't
do much to it I'll strap it on and again
that's really weird okay so that didn't
do anything either we have a max width
on our cards that's why okay I didn't
realize that we brought over a max width
on our card here let's let's see what we
get now okay now we have much wider
cards which is gonna allow us to display
more text but it also kind of messes up
the the images a bit so it seems like
the images are still acting like they
have a height a max height maybe let's
get rid of this for now and let's double
check our our media classes media yeah
we're not we're not gonna pull that in
anymore whoa all right let's just kind
of mess with the settings then on our
own so let's just let's mess with this
one okay so we have an actual image
[Music]
background sighs see this background
shouldn't matter anymore right because
we're using an image instead hmm max
width height oh we do have a max Heights
though and that's coming from all right
then okay so our max height is is
actually coming from a file that we're
using on that page so let's get rid of
that let's get rid of that that entire
file for now in in terms of just you
know importing it on this particular
page on our alumni list page so we can
see here we're bringing in this faculty
dot CSS which I believe yeah let's get
rid of that let's get rid of these files
completely get rid of this head
component completely and see what it
looks like without that okay and let's
see what we have now okay so now we're
displaying everything on these cards but
they're gonna be uneven they're gonna
display you know much differently
okay I'd rather start from this and then
try to make them more uniform and at
least we know what we're dealing with in
terms of being able to see the actual
image dimensions okay all right let me
check my time Oh two more minutes okay
here's what I want to do for the next
step I want to see what this content is
actually going to look like oh yeah
alumni card and we're bringing in the
content let's use I always forget how to
use this actually you know what I have
this we're using it already somewhere
we're using this
probably in one of these pages let's see
page nope so that's that's a query let's
just go to our page is cuz I'm pretty
sure this component is using what I
would want to use yeah so we're gonna do
a dangerously set enter HTML and add
content in there and so that's what
we'll add here and I want to get rid of
everything actually I do
okay let's see we may have to change and
not have a P there like a P tag I was it
working this time there was some weird
bug where we had to use a span but it
looks like this is this is working
better okay I definitely don't want to
click effect on here so we'll get rid of
that at some point but this will show at
least we got the HTML tags out of there
so it looks like some of the newer
profiles that we have are really short
and some of the older ones sort of like
full page length I mean this one even
has you know subheadings and things like
that so I think probably will end up not
even showing some of the older ones hey
I mean this person graduated in 2003
this person graduated college before I
did so we want to do you know probably
some some newer profiles okay all right
so that's the the second timer is up so
I'm gonna go do some questions now the
next step would just be taking these and
I guess what I would probably need to do
then is only show just a little bit of
the text
maybe if we wanted to use them all show
a little bit and then truncate that and
then keep that learn more link and show
the full amount of data on a page yes so
we could definitely do that that way we
get out of it a little bit more uniform
in terms of height with these images we
would probably do the same thing where
we would set a max height but be
generous with our max height so that it
could show everything but we're not
gonna get really huge images like was
there's one down here that was really
long I can't see it yeah like this one
ends up being really long all right so
we would we would want to cut down on
that some of these images just aren't
high enough quality they're they're
little pixelated so those would be the
next steps and then in terms of
displaying them other places we would
just want to do a similar thing that we
did with this this map our alumni list
so we mapped over everything so we can
either use this same query and then when
we map we could also do a filter first
before we map and we do a dot filter and
filter out for just those particular
students who majored in a certain area
right or just the ones that we want to
feature on the front page or the
alternative would be that we modify our
our query so that we only return the
data that we want instead of returning
everything and looping through it so
probably long run it would be better to
just get the data that we want but
either way for now would work since
there's really not that much data it
wouldn't be an issue in terms of
performance
but those would be the next steps I'm
gonna commit all this and have it up on
the github repo links in the description
so if you want to check out what we've
done here
it'll it'll be available soon after I'm
finished and right now I'm gonna go back
to the live chat try to figure out where
I left off at and answer all your
questions or as many as I possibly can
let's see preferences our videos are in
a playlist as projects I want to see
from the start of the project yeah this
is project 5 so there's a playlist for
project 5 each project has its own
playlist oh sorry
see on in here so V web code asks why is
Redux important also how long did it
take you to learn and match the react
and redux I would say I'm not a master
Redux was tricky but it was still
something I learned it maybe I don't
know a week or two when I was taking the
Udacity react nano degree and we
learning Redux you know that portion of
it probably took a week or two to be
able to build something that
successfully used Redux Redux is
important when you need when you have
some complex state management that needs
to happen then that's when Redux is
important so for instance if you find
yourself passing State down through
several levels of child components all
right then maybe you might want to think
about some state management solution you
know other than local state so Redux
Apollo has something similar built in
now you could use reacts new context API
so you Redux isn't the only option
there's also mob X so you have some
options but when your app starts to get
complex and handling state through just
local state is starts to get complicated
um then you might want to think of a
different solution for for handling
state and that's where Redux comes in
and things like Redux
I'm trying to I'm skipping through a
little bit so to just get some questions
I see there are some comments in here to
read out more if I have time but I want
to make sure it gets all the questions
let's see
Melo's asks how are you Jessie do you
remember me I remember I kind of
remember I'll be loose in the chat so I
don't remember what we talked about
before but how's it going thanks for for
joining us
Leonard as says 25 right now just
graduating with BS and information
system programming and my too late for
this profession you were definitely not
too late for this profession there are
people getting into this profession all
the time who are way older than you so
definitely that's a frequent question
that that I see here and elsewhere
definitely not too old I'm in asked how
to become a best software engineer
practice so the more you build things
the better you will be so practice and
practice doing things the right way so
read the documentation stay up to date
on the latest ways of doing things for
whatever particular area you're in and
you'll you'll get better code with Oh
head says you're awesome Jesse Thanks
I appreciate that if you web coaches do
you know the merge stack yeah what is
that [ __ ] express react and node is
that mine yeah yeah I mean that's
basically what we use like I mean right
now we're not using [ __ ] but yeah I'm
familiar with with the merge stay
Chandan says love from India hey how's
it going thank you
let's see a key says I tried Gatsby why
don't people use it more although I know
how much is but I read its ratio right
I don't know me gasps Keys gasp he's a
great a great tool so I don't know why
people don't use it more honestly maybe
they just haven't heard about it I'm not
really sure but I've been impressed with
Gatsby
also helmet js4 SEO yeah yeah you want
trying to think we're using a helmet to
add things into the head tag and react
I believe that's what what it's used for
so you'd want like your metadata that
should go in the in the head head tag
for SEO you would use it for that
Mila says what do you need to go into
electrical engineering
I honestly have no idea about electrical
engineering so I don't I've never done
that kind of thing so I'm really not
sure up high from Uganda hey how's it
going hey from Bangladesh Hey
Fred asks if we'll tackle testing react
I'd love to do more with testing I'm not
sure when that would happen that we
would do a show on testing but I think
that's a great idea
ray asked what my youtube channel is
check the description for this video and
you'll find a link to my youtube channel
Twitter and Instagram
I believe my channel is J or as a Jessie
why Bowl I don't even know my channel is
maybe it's like Jessie Weigel 29
something like that oh yeah Umberto's
says Jessie Michael 29 yeah that's it
phosphorus says you used Jekyll no I
don't I don't remember I don't think
I've used Jekyll I I remember looking
into it but I'm not sure if I ever
actually used it V Webb code says what
is react framework like next yes Apollo
why do we need them please explain yeah
so something like next J s or create
react app will help you get started with
the react project it'll build out a lot
of the structure and handle all your
webpack config next also handles things
like server-side rendering so you would
want to use them to just get a jumpstart
on things for react and for most
projects they'll work you know you don't
need custom webpack stuff going on and
that can be a big barrier to entry if
you're not a webpack expert like I'm
definitely not I don't want to have to
mess with that just to get you know a
simple react app build Apollo is
different Apollo allows you to use
really sorry about the onion Apollo
allows you to use graph QL with react so
it's it's gonna be a it's gonna help you
bring that data in make sure you get it
where you need to in your app to the
right components and help you handle
state m40 says how long you been
programming I'm currently working on my
JavaScript skills and I think I will
look for a job in a couple of months as
a front-end developer in Poland I've
been programming for I think six years
now so I think that's great you're gonna
be looking for a job I'd say yeah you
know and there's no need to really wait
to try to find a job you know you could
certainly start applying for you know
right now and you know all you need to
get a job as a programmer
to convince somebody that to hire you
right it's there's not like some test
you have to pass right if you can you
know every company is gonna have
different things they do in the
interview you know different questions
they ask somebody might even not ask a
technical question but you know don't I
would say don't keep thinking like oh I
need to get better before I apply you
know let let your potential employers
decide you know because if you're you
know a perfectionist type of person you
might keep saying I need to get better I
need to get better and meanwhile people
with less experience than you or are
getting jobs right so you can learn on
the job you don't have to do all the
learning person and get the job you're
always gonna be learning so you may as
well get paid for it right
that's absolutely I feel V Webb code I'm
learning react I want to know why it is
the best framework out there I don't
know if reacts the best or not right
it's react is an option that that will
work well there are other options in in
JavaScript land that will also work well
so I don't think what's the best is the
right question it's what is gonna work
for for this particular project that I'm
working on based on what resources I
have what skills that I have and what
the what are the requirements for the
project
teddy bear says are you programming in
Mac or Windows I am on a Mac right now
Samba desks about which vs code
extensions I'm using and which ones are
good for yak development get react food
truck it will start you out with a bunch
of different plugins that basically the
majority of the extensions I'm using
four vs code have come from react food
trucks so look that up it's one
extension once you get that it'll come
with a lot of other extensions that will
help you with react be webco's is can I
use WebSocket with react or real-time
apps yeah I mean I don't see why you you
couldn't
use it with react if anybody knows of a
reason why you know let me know
phosphorus is why Visual Studio code not
Adam I found Visual Studio code to be a
little faster than Adam I haven't used
Adam recently but when I did switch
which probably a year ago or so the is
code was a bit faster
I used to use out in four years I use
that V web code says I'm learning react
right now and you recommend any udemy
courses I have not taken any react udemy
courses so I don't know which ones are
good or not
Alex says will this be archived on this
YouTube channel yes it will yeah it'll
be available v web says if I build a
login system with firebase and react
without any back-end can anybody break
my app oh I don't know I mean there's
always I guess I mean I always assume if
somebody had enough time and money and
talent they could break anything right
so I don't want to say that they
couldn't break it but you know if you're
relying on in this case Google to handle
your database then you know a big
company like Google I'm sure has a lot
of safeguards in place that you might
not think to put in place if you're
doing it yourself
you know from scratch so it would
probably decrease the likelihood of
somebody being able to hack into your
app watch watch rfo says what do you do
i am i get i program i build websites
and web apps and particularly with
javascript and react kami says what you
take on CSS frameworks like bootstrap
materialize and CSS with react did they
make react up slow you can use
materialized and bootstrap with react in
fact one of the projects we did use
materialized with react the problem is a
lot of the the interactive things that
happen don't
use react state to make it happen so
it's you're gonna miss out on a lot of
the benefits of react in terms of their
their rendering the speed so I would you
know instead of materialized use
material UI or it's gonna work with
reacts state management and I think
there is a bootstrap equivalent as well
so it's you can make them work but it's
not gonna be as optimized as fast as it
would be if you used react state
management to manipulate the dawn right
you never want to manipulate the Dom
directly when you're using react you
always want to do things through state
and with bootstrap and materialize
you're gonna be manipulating the Dom
directly so better better not to use
them master nameless is what's a good
simple training project to do to
practice coding I mean I just check out
some of the projects in free code camp
free code camp or check out the projects
and to get some ideas for that this is
also if you consider turning on your
YouTube super chat not for free code
camps channel that would be a decision
for you know Quincy who's in charge of
free code camp on my own channel I don't
know maybe I'd turn it on I don't even
know if I qualify to be able to turn it
on to be honest but you know I've
thought about it before but for now I'm
you know I'm okay with this the web says
is github repo important for getting a
job when I am looking to hire candidates
which isn't often but I if you have a
github repo then I will take a closer
look at you as a candidate so I want to
see your code and having a github repo
makes it very easy for me to see that
see what exactly you've contributed so I
definitely recommend having a github
profile you know with some some of your
better work on it if you're trying to
look for a job and make sure you put a
to that on your resume m40 says is it
better to stick with an L a JavaScript
or jQuery or maybe both vanilla
JavaScript is going to be more versatile
and you'll be able to use it you know in
more places but it's good to know a
little about jQuery because a lot of
websites use jQuery so the odds of you
having to work on it at some point
especially if you're gonna work on old
websites for clients or even for
companies you're probably gonna see
jQuery it's not that hard to learn so
wouldn't you know worry about knowing it
or not knowing it but you're probably
gonna come across it at some point but
if you're just trying to really learn
you know JavaScript you can stick with
another JavaScript and that's gonna be a
good way to go and then just pick up
jQuery when you when you need it if you
ever do Mb terms is what kind of
projects can I make with react
oh really anything I mean really like
anything you that's out there on the
internet could probably be built with
react is it best to motor with react I
don't know but you could you could do it
I mean even like native apps you can
make with react if you're using electron
as well you can make dev subset apps
with react so there's a lot you can do
with with react
MB trem says is there any tutorial for
react and firebase for beginners there's
probably a tutorial out there I don't
really remember one off the top of my
head but I bet there there's probably
more than one out there
the web says how much should I code
every day to be really good at coding
you know you don't know obviously the
more coding you do the better you'll be
but I would if you could dedicate like
an hour a day then you're gonna keep
getting better right if you could do
more do more it depends on how much time
you have but if you if you're spending
your whole day playing video games then
maybe spend your own a coding right if
you have a job or two jobs and you gotta
provide for yourself
your family or whoever then try to get
that half hour in right but it just it
kind of just depends on on you and how
much time you really do have Samba and I
don't have anything against video games
I'm just saying like if your goal is to
be good at coding then you know code
more if you can't Sam it says is it
possible bit of progressive web app with
react this front-end and go Lang is back
in you can definitely build a pressive
web app with react to the front-end I
don't know very much at all about Galang
but you can pretty much use reacted with
whatever back end you want so I'm
assuming that that is possible Rajan
says which language is best for
beginners it kind of depends on what you
want to do but if I had to pick I would
say javascript is good because you can
run it in the browser you don't need to
download anything extra
Python is also good because the syntax
is is pretty simple to understand so
those would be my two languages that if
you're not interested in web development
at all then go with Python if you are
interested in web development go with
JavaScript Josh
Eric Smith says what do you think of
WordPress with react we're using
WordPress WordPress with react right now
headless WordPress I think it's a nice
combination because so many companies
already run WordPress so if they wanted
something more modern then in terms of
their front-end with react you could
very easily use the data they already
have and you know their workflow would
change very little in terms of content
updating an entry but they could have
react you know on the front end use
react for you know they're at their add
their mobile app and still pull the data
from WordPress so I think it's a it's a
good combination in some situations I
wouldn't use it all the time but I think
it's a really nice way to transition
people into react without you know
causing them to have to learn you know a
ton of new stuff
for maintenance the web says do you have
a CS degree I do not my degrees in
business do you have bosses how many
projects I need to build a powerful
portfolio I don't know what that number
is but honestly like I would like to see
at least three projects on a portfolio
if somebody is trying to apply for
something if somebody claims they're an
expert at something I want to see a lot
more than three projects you know
honestly unless those three projects are
like amazing and huge then yeah I'd want
to say so it depends on what your what
kind of role you're trying to get right
if it's an entry level like junior
developer role then try for three good
ones right I'd rather have three good
ones then you know ten ones that are
just like terrible or just very very
basic to do apps or something like that
MB trance is is reacting react native
same in syntax coding they're very
similar there are a few differences
between react and react native but if
you know react it will be pretty easy to
go over into react native if you have
been learn react native first which is
more rare it will be pretty easy to go
and just do things and react so just
just a few differences Amara says what
are products based companies which
provide job opportunities and react Jas
there are a lot of companies that use
react so obviously Facebook users reacts
and then Instagram because right they're
owned by Facebook trying to think what
else sees your act Netflix users react
Eventbrite users react I don't know I
don't know the list there if you look up
like what companies use react you you'll
get a lot of info there's a lot of
companies using react right now Go
Daddy's websites but with react
WordPress is switching over to a lot of
stuff being
so that company is I believe is called
automatic is the the WordPress company
so there are a lot of companies using
react right now you know just you know
do a search even go on like a job board
and do a search for react as a keyword
and you know you'll see a lot of blood
I've been knowing that lately it I there
are a lot of jobs chris says how do you
solve a design problem more and model
there I'm not sure what you mean about
model layer but to be honestly I don't
use a lot of design tools I'm more of a
coder developer and less of a designer
so I'm I'm a little bit more comfortable
just adjusting some CSS than actually
going to something like you know sketch
or Adobe XD or you know something along
those lines
so if I'm already working on the project
and there's some design stuff I just
switched the code up if it's brand new
and I have an action code or anything
yet then maybe I would do things in in
sketch I you know I do you sketch
occasionally the web says thanks Jesse
you are helping us a lot oh you're
welcome I got to keep an eye on the time
all right I'm gonna I got half hour
throw my phone interview Eldrick says is
it possible for me to learn c-sharp
language as a beginner yeah I mean it's
possible it's just a matter of sticking
with it practicing studying building
things Rodrigo says hi Jesse thanks for
this lesson what IDE are you using and
is it possible to code react for iOS in
Linux yeah for sure I'm using Visual
Studio code you can code with react on
any operating system Windows Mac Linux
you know whatever and then you can use
react native to build iOS apps so that's
definitely possible
skee 760 says random question but how do
I set up nginx to work with react router
on refresh without getting a 404
yeah it should be fine so there
shouldn't really be anything you need to
set up for nginx right nginx just needs
to route your traffic all traffic to
your server Jas file or whatever using
with react router and then react router
will handle everything
rector I know on refresher that I do 404
it's been so long since I've set that up
I don't remember what if anything
special you have to do I'm assuming that
there's some documentation about it
though but yeah it's been way too long
since I've I've set up nginx manually
m40 says I worked with jQuery a little
is pretty straightforward but I feel
more confident with vanilla JavaScript
feel like I can do much more with it
yeah I mean vanilla JavaScript you you
can end up doing more because you're not
locked into the jquery api which it's
very versatile but still it there are
some restrictions oxygen Exedy says why
don't you start a tutorial series on
react yes I might it's just you know
it's a lot of work to you know actually
set up an actual tutorials so you know
that's it's potentially you know it
could happen though it says what are
some new trends you see in the
programming industry I I don't really
know um new trends there's so much you
know new going on all the time right
everybody is jumping on the machine
learning you know like like all
industries are getting in on machine
learning some of the coolest stuff now I
think or the potential would be most
helpful is in the medical industry I
think that that's a really awesome place
to be because your programming work
could actually end up saving people's
lives so that's that's awesome also the
work with a are so like augmented
reality is
which you know there are ways to use
react JavaScript with that you know and
that I think that has a lot more
applications than people realize it's
not just entertainment gaming but there
are applications for industry medicine
you know things like that too so those
are some of the areas that I think are
pretty cool also the cryptocurrencies
are great you know not not investment
stuff but in terms of having distributed
systems for keeping track of things like
let's say like real estate ownership
you know identification even things like
like voting is they're doing tests with
using blockchain stuff for that I don't
know there's a lot of cool areas where I
think it could benefit from a
decentralized ledger system that that
you have with with these blockchain
technologies James tells us how can I
learn react you know read the
documentation check out some react
tutorials so there's there's a lot of
them out there depending on how you like
to learn you know maybe you want to get
a book maybe you want to read blogs
videos you know they're they're out
there a Martha's window discover the
right time to jump into Redux get into
Redux if you find your apps if it starts
to get really hard to think about your
estate and keep your state managed
properly then you want to think about
Redux or something like it
Chris X's design problem model layer I
mean I started a Java dev I have a
project for myself then I run into a use
case to solve and wonder how should I
write or add classes to solve it yeah I
I mean I'm not a job in dev so I'm not
sure specifically what you know what you
run into but I mean I do run into cases
where the you know things happen in a
project and you have to
you have to do actually add extra
components and things like that so I
mean I'm not sure usually my my process
is like just get it fixed get it working
and then look at how you could do it
better you know sometimes it has to be a
quick fix you just have to do it the
best you can and then hopefully you have
time to go back afterwards optimize it
you know V Webb says have you managed
CSS inside react there's a lot of
different ways you could do it
you could use regular style sheets and
just import them like you normally would
you could use CSS nsj components write
inline CSS a lot of different ways to do
it I'm not really sure which is the best
one Omar says is react version 17 going
to be a big change in terms of learning
it's going to be some big changes but I
don't think it's gonna be huge in terms
of learning much of react is going to
stay the same but there's gonna be some
cool new stuff as well the UF says do
you think machine learning will take
over web development no not really I
think a lot of the things the machine
learning are is good at it's not
necessarily the same thing that makes a
web developer good so it it could
potentially be used to help as a tool
and web development but I don't see it
no I I haven't heard of anything let's
get that is probably gonna significantly
change web development in in the
short-term future a few websites what is
required to start freelancing as a web
developer find somebody who wants to pay
you to do web stuff that's it I mean
it's depending on your country maybe you
need some sort of license to do business
but really you just find somebody who
one who's gonna pay you to do work and
that's about it ego says D you already
use reactive databases what do you think
about this tech I'm I'm not sure
yeah I'm not exactly sure what reactive
databases are so I I guess I have no
opinion about it right now
edmond says hey I'm just an amateur but
I need to learn to code learn coding and
be a pro at programming need more of
your tutorials help out yeah I mean
there's it so many tutorials on here
like me personally there's I think over
200 videos right now that I've done so
there's a bunch for they're just on this
channel and then there are a ton of
other contributors that have done a lot
so definitely this there's a lot of
material for you to go through here just
with free code camp let's see Aki says
thought to mob X versus redux I haven't
used my back so I really can't I can't
compare amor says is it compulsory to
know about component lifecycle perfectly
no I mean not perfectly right you need
to know enough to make it work right
having a general understanding of what
the component lifecycle is is definitely
important in react m40 says have you
heard of red javascript and jquery by
john Duquette because i have very good
things about the spoken thing about
reading it I have not read it so I and I
haven't really heard much about it so I
can't really give a good opinion on that
Ava says why have you chosen Gatsby what
problems are solving XS so I'm not using
Gatsby for this project
Davis eases my uncle Reese's glucose
level with a Bluetooth Bluetooth in from
implant that's awesome that is really
cool Marius wants to know my theme and
vision vs code its SETI the you can see
how to spell in everything in the
description to the video V Webb says
what are the main ways to make money
after learning coding building building
websites working fixing websites so
either freelancing or you know getting a
job with a company Eva says looks very
similar sorry oh yeah yeah no problem
I mean we're still using react so you
know whether it's reactive gas feed
creator a cab
next yes whatever you know it's all
gonna look very similar so okay I've got
the end of the questions and my
interview is coming up very soon so I'm
gonna take a break here rest my voice
for a minute and I will maybe I'll
stream later on I know I have two
meetings later today so I may or may not
stream on my channel but subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications links
in the description to my channel if I do
end up live-streaming you should get in
to notification about it and I do have
some other videos on there if you'd like
to check it out feel free to follow me
on Instagram and Twitter links are also
in the description so hopefully I'll see
y'all soon in any case have a great day
thank you so much for watching